uh now should we get Labor's take this
morning we can talk to the shadow
leveling up secretary uh Lisa and nandy
who joins us now from Central London
thanks very much for uh being with us
and we just heard from you're not in
central London are you apologies you're
on Wigan and this is the kind of thing
to get very uh to get right now we just
heard from Mark Harper he's obviously
adopting a softer tone towards the
unions but he was pretty clear that
public sector at pay Rises that match
inflation or bust inflation are
unaffordable are they
well well they're unaffordable because
of 12 Years of Tory government and 44
days in which Liz truss and
quasiquarteng crashed the economy and I
think there ought to be a level of
humility about that within government
what he should be doing is moving Heaven
and Earth to try and avert strikes
coming up this winter it's been a really
tough year for a lot of people and
nobody wants to see strikes least of all
the people who are having to resort to
strike action it's worth noting that
we're in this position because ministers
have been refusing to meet the workforce
for some considerable time it's very
welcome that Mark Harper has taken a
different approach met with the rmt this
week and by all accounts it was a very
positive meeting but it is ludicrous
that were weeks away from more strike
action and we're congratulating a
government Minister for simply turning
up and doing the very Bare Basics of his
job
at the very beginning that answer you
said that public sector pay Rises that
match inflation are unaffordable because
of the conservatives I'm just interested
in that line because Andy Burnham said
you know he's right behind the nurses
covert claps don't pay the bills are you
saying that actually realistically
inflation busting pay Rises including
the 19 being asked for by nurses are
actually unaffordable
well look the truth is I don't know the
government hasn't opened the books to us
so in the case of nurses for example
we're not privy to National Health
Service negotiations and it will be
absurd for me to try and conduct those
negotiations live on air what I can tell
you is that if we were in government we
would be treating the nurses as partners
they haven't been on strike for 106
years and they've had to resort to
strike action because the health
secretary Stephen Barkley wouldn't even
meet them over the summer until it was
confirmed that the strikes were going
ahead I was in my local hospital just
yesterday talking to nurses talking to
the management they're trying to work
out how they're going to get through
those days of strike action together and
keep patients safe they would much
rather be at work and one of the things
that we've proposed that would help to
ease that burden is to scrap non-don tax
status and expand the NHS Workforce
because part of the problem that they've
got is not just that they can't afford
to put food on the table for their
families but they're overworked and
burnt out and they don't know how they
can go on like this
um you were pictured on a picket line in
Wigan with striking workers back in
August would you be joining a picket
line with the nurses
I'm not planning to go down to the
picket line because when I spoke to
members of the Royal College of Nursing
and to the General Secretary of Unison
they like left me in no doubt that where
they want me is in Parliament doing my
job so that they can do theirs and one
of the few people in this country who
can actually demand that ministers come
into Parliament and hold their feet to
the fire we're going to dial up the
pressure on government ministers who've
been utterly complacent in order to get
them around that negotiating table and
get a negotiated settlement it is
possible I know that because I've spoken
to nurses across the country including
here in Wigan in just the last few days
they desperately want to avoid that
strike action and they're only here
after 106 years because of a government
that refused to negotiate with them the
problem in this country is not militant
workers it's a militant government
uh now today you've got some new
research out that you say shows that
leveling up isn't working according to
your analysis uh 568 million pounds has
been lost from leveling up funds due to
inflation so does that mean that labor
would like to spend an extra half a
billion pounds on leveling up
no but we will keep promises that we
make unlike this government they've made
huge promises that the last general
election that they were going to level
up this country and now they've had to
pull their Flagship legislation they've
wasted weeks of council's time on bids
for investment zones that have now gone
into the bin they had 12 leveling up
director posts which they advertised at
the start of this year that are still
not in place and now we've found out
that 560 million has been wiped off the
value of those funds because of their
disastrous handling of the economy it's
a poor poor record for something that
was the ticket
to electoral success for the
conservatives at the last election and
at the next election we're going to come
come in win the trust of the people back
and start to set this right
and this week UK net migration hit an
all-time high 504
100
000. is that something we should be
comfortable with because there are
vacancies in the job market or is it
something that labor would like to see a
number that labor would like to see come
down
I think that very high levels of
immigration are unsustainable because we
haven't invested in our young people
we're really proud here in Wigan of the
fact that we're able to attract people
to come from all over the world and work
in our National Health Service but for
young people who live just a few streets
away from our local hospital they might
as well as dream of going to the Moon as
to getting a job there because the
nursing bursary has been abolished and
the education maintenance allowance and
aim higher and all of the things that
built the ladder that helped them to get
there so we believe in an immigration a
points-based immigration system that's
what we introduced when we're in
government but we want to align that
much more closely to skills so that we
first invest in our young people to be
able to get the jobs that exist and then
look to fill vacancies and ask
immigrants to come here because they
make a significant contribution in order
to fill those gaps
there's been a bit of confusion shall I
say and actually from from myself as
well about you know what Labor's
position is when it comes to migration
kissed armor uh gave a speech didn't he
last week to the CBI and the Daily
Telegraph headline was starma you came
as wean itself of Migrant labor the
headline on the independent was Labor
pledges to relax immigration rules what
is kostama's position on immigration
does he think it's too high or do you
think does he think there should be more
of it
well we want to see the government that
invests in young people in Britain first
and foremost to fill labor shortages but
we recognize too that immigration has a
significant contribution to make not
least at the moment where you've got
short-term gaps in the labor market that
currently can't be filled so last
Christmas there was a consensus that
during the petrol crisis it would be
worth relaxing rules temporarily to get
hgv drivers to be able to deliver petrol
and keep the country moving but we want
to see a sensible approach to
immigration with a plan and at the
moment what we've got this is this
absurd situation where the government
floats these ideas like cutting foreign
student numbers which is their latest
only two weeks ago the higher education
Minister was bragging about the fact
that they'd attracted 600 000 students
to come and study here in Britain a
decade earlier and now we've got
ministers posturing saying that they're
going to crack down on the very people
that just two weeks ago they were
begging to come here we need a serious
plan to fill our labor shortages and
invest in young people here in Britain
not these back of the [ __ ] packet
policies that unravel as soon as they're
announced now you published a book this
week all in how we build a country that
works I just want to read you the first
line of the new Statesman review that
says there's an alternate universe in
which Lisa Mandy won the 2020 labor
leadership election for anyone I'm
wishing to imagine the kind of leader
she would have been her new book all in
will help so what would be the main
difference in labor policy then if you'd
won in 2020 rather than kirstama
well I think the fact that I'm writing
this book and I was tasked with care in
thinking through how we're going to
rebuild this country from the ground up
drawing on the contribution and the
potential and the Assets in every person
in every part of Britain shows you that
we are a team and that we're drawing on
the strengths of very different parts of
our labor movement in order to speak
directly to the country that it's been a
significant privilege to serve his
shadow foreign secretary but when I was
moved into this position a year ago it
was because we know that the only way
that we're going to rebuild this country
is by recognizing the contribution that
people have to make in every part of
Britain that's been written off and
written out of the national Story by
this government we're determined to set
this right that's what this book's about
and here is full fully behind the fact
that we've we've got to have not just a
critique of the Tories but be a genuine
alternative that's what he was setting
out this week that's what Rachel Reeves
has been setting out and that's what
I've helped to set out in this book that
was released this week very quickly
because I do have to let you go Matt
Hancock know the final of I'm a
celebrity you know politicians normally
get voted out first why do you think
he's done so well
I don't know but I think he should be at
work he's still being paid to be a
member of Parliament and if he's
anything like me he'll be absolutely
overwhelmed with cases of people who
just don't know how they're going to get
through the hardest winter imaginable
because the Tory government of which he
was a central part has crashed the
economy and left people paying the price
and he needs to get out of that jungle
get back to work and start repairing
some of that damage
okay listen Andy thank you very much
indeed